so from John Kumi uh we've got a few
slides just saying what the climate
challenge really is and what this two
degree limit is about and i' I've really
condensed this so if you're really
interested in seeing him speak we can
probably get the video from last year
when he and Terry did this I'm not sure
it's one of the ones that on YouTube
right now and as I say you'll hear a lot
about him from here basically he he you
know when I got interested in this back
in 2006 there was still a considerable
amount of dancing do humans cause it did
humans not you know here it is you know
he's he's got up here this quote from
the National Academy of Sciences years
ago 2010 just saying you know a strong
credible body says you know that this
is
that this is really um true that the
Earth system is warming and much of the
warming is very likely due to us so
despite the fact that the earth's
climate system goes through cycles and
all of that what we're in the middle of
right now is extraordinary and it seems
you know the National Academy of
Sciences at least says and many more do
right that hey and it's something we're
doing and one thing very remarkable if
you go back this goes back 800,000 years
is what the bottom axis is so minus
800,000 800,000 years ago to now we've
gone through many cycles in CO2
concentration and you can see it bopping
around between you know 180 250 maybe
going up a while here it peaked at 300
here 300,000 years ago bopping around
bopping around and then you get to
1900 and something extraordinary happens
we're outside the range that we've been
at before and this was u a year or two
ago I think too um yeah 2012 point so
it's even jumped farther as far as I
have heard and that's really interesting
we're running an unintended experiment
it seems on our
climate and you know
it's because we have an atmosphere we're
not uh a very cold Rock like like the
moon right um and so it makes sense that
if you're changing the composition of
the atmosphere you're going to change
the set point really of that balance of
where where does your temperature
equilibrate uh when you're balancing the
incoming radiation versus what's getting
reradiated and so we changed that set
point
some um at least that's that's the claim
my particular work I don't need to take
a position on that but this seems to me
very credible and very well well stated
um and then we've got what happens to
our gases what's what's going on here if
the predictions it uh that John Kumi is
quoting again soov um what's going to
happen to our CO2 our methane nitrous
oxide other gases if we have no policy
so this is just the no policy case how
does it look like things go and by the
way every plot that I've looked at since
getting into this we'll do some sort of
what's the no policy case what was the
prediction for now and every time you
look at that from well what actually did
happen now versus what they predicted
back a few years ago we always seem to
come out worse higher so uh so this is
saying that by 2100 we'll be at 4.8
times pre-industrial levels and CO2 is
the greenhouse gas you hear a lot about
but methane is a stronger one and that's
natural gas and that's uh that's
released when permafrost melts and it's
you know it's it's there's a lot of it
and so and and it increasingly is the
threat that there will be increasing
amounts of methane too so this isn't
great and so MIT no policy case then
says well that means by 2100 we we may
well be up 5 degre C from the Baseline
and the Baseline was you know sort of
historical till you know 1900 or so when
we started taking off well why do we
care right I mean if you're living in
Canada or Alaska you might think gee I'd
like it to be warmer well not
necessarily um I don't know what all
that's about and so the ipcc the inter
governmental panel on climate change
which is a un supervised body of
scientists I think most of them
volunteer on this put together these
climate change assessments uh every few
years and that's what a lot of these
predictions come from it's a bunch of
scientists making best faith effort to
have a consensus on where's climate
going and usually what they come out
with uh can strike the public as kind of
alarmist but they're doing their best to
be un alarmist they're doing their best
to uh make sure that they don't
overstate the facts because you don't
want to be accused of being alarmist and
so from those you know there are all
these predictions the most recent
assessment report how much CO2 is gone
up what Arctic summer sea ice extent is
what the global average upper ocean heat
content is what the global average sea
level change is impacts that affect us
all of these what is the global mean sea
level rise thought to be maybe about a
meter in the worst case projection
remember what we've seen so far is we
always seem to exceed the worst case
that people can bear to predict um maybe
a meter up from what it is now by the
end of the century think what that means
to so much of just this country and then
think about Coastal Nations islands
around the world what's going to
happen uh the last time I could bear to
look at it the MIT Greenhouse gamble
with its no policy case this is just a
beautiful way to present probability
wedges I love this thing picture picture
somebody up here spinning this Wheel of
Fortune and
goinging oh thank goodness I lucked out
I met this less than one degre C hooray
but what are the chances of that so this
is what it was back of few years ago um
the last time I could bear to check it
this is what it had become so everything
everything from here to here this more
than 50% chances here of ending up below
3° C by 2100 has now in their
predictions collapsed to this teeny
wedge and now things that we didn't even
dare think about you know well there's a
pretty decent chance we may go up by
more than 7° see that's a pretty
alarming prediction that's no policy
prediction why do we care Terry root
Professor Terry root put together with a
um graphic artist the uh findings from
the ipcc fourth assessment I was just
showing you some from the more recent
fifth assessment in a graphic form of
why do we care if things go up you know
a degree c 2 degre C 5 degre C and the
ones that grabbed me at that point and
said my gosh I'm thinking about the
world for my kids and here's the Web of
Life as We Know It disappearing I that's
not acceptable I wonder what I can do um
20 to 30% of known species greater risk
of Extinction they say even with that
two degre c limit that people talk about
is well maybe we can tolerate that and
you go upwards of that and they're no
longer saying greater risk they're
saying Extinction but there's so many
more here too economic Global losses up
to 5% of the global GDP malnutrition
infectious diseases droughts you know W
uh lots of um uh wildfires which we're
seeing increasing Wildfire risk just bad
stuff so that's there's a lot of reasons
why we would care I'm now going to go
from quoting some of John kum's slides
and some of mine to quoting some of
Terry Root's slides so she specializes
she's one of the co-recipients of the
Nobel Prize being one of the lead ipcc
people her husband her late husband
Steve Schneider was really prominent in
understanding and getting the word out
on climate change as well they were an
amazing team and she is ing the work she
she is just amazing and her specialty is
looking at what climate change pressures
on species are and so so her slides are
beautifully graphic this is what she
talked about last time and I as I say I
can dig out that video if you guys want
I think I could probably put that on our
coursework site um just what are the
biotic interactions how do the species
adapt to warming what's the future what
happens when species can't adapt is
there anything we can do and so she put
in some some examples for instance she
speaks much more eloquently than I about
this and I do have a video clip I grab
that if we have time I could run at the
end uh at some um conference that was
just nicely concise but she talked about
you know the unintended consequences of
doing things without complete knowledge
you know well you've got wolves and
you've got coyotes and just the
interaction as you're trying to displace
some species and you find whoops now
this one's dominating and that's got a
problem the coyotes are whoops now the
red foxes are and oh gee by the way
we've wiped out the Wolves you know when
humans meddle with this stuff we really
have to do it in a way that keeps in
mind there are always unintended
consequences and just understand how
limited our understanding is that
doesn't mean we shouldn't do anything I
devote a lot of my life to trying to
develop something that I think maybe we
should do or at least have in our back
pocket but we should understand there
should be an undo switch for things that
we do that have um um
good
effects what kind of adaptations can you
have to climate change what can you do
well one thing uh that creatures do is
they shift if things are getting too hot
they shift poleward right they shift
where it's colder or they can go up in
elevation until they run out of room
okay so there's some something you can
if you can do that but what if you are
shifting you bird who can travel but all
your food doesn't
suddenly your ranges aren't overlapping
anymore a bird is certainly going to be
able to move at a different rate than
than the vegetation that it feeds on
does and so you start getting all of
these types of pressures I don't think I
left in the one um there's also you you
can end up in areas now where there's a
new predator or there's no you know um
it it's just things weren't evolved that
way and so it puts enormous pressures on
them when suddenly they're in a
completely different e EOS system than
they evolved with the background
Extinction rate historically was
something like less than one specie in a
th species over a thousand years but
what it is now is one in 10 species over
a thousand years so that has instead of
1 in a thousand it's gone up to 1 in 10
which is really alarming again I'm not
an expert in this but I trust what the
scientists are telling
us that's pretty alarming that says we
are just coming into the sixth I think
great mass extinction event unless we
can do something um and so what if we go
up 3.6 degrees Fahrenheit now not C
we'll expect from the ipcc assessment
400,000 species go extinct up 7.2 a
million species go extinct so that's
pretty dire if you believe that we as
humans even if we didn't care about
other species which some of us do deeply
but even if we only cared about humans
if our Web of Life goes away I think we
get in trouble too so back to John Kumi
now so that's that's some of the effects
of powering back here that's some of the
effects of temperature rising here's a
lot about extinction species um what
John Kumi says is but wait there's some
hope um forecasts often tell us we can't
change so quickly basically they don't
take into into account the power of
innovation and so one of the big tenets
that I love in this book is that a lot
of entrepreneurs working in parallel
failing forward quickly you know trying
things seeing what works abandoning what
doesn't work and just keep finding you
know designing to the right solution
that we can proceed much more quickly
than what an economic forecast of well
this is existing technology this is all
we can do would predict and and so you
know here's here's a sort of sobering
Cal Calvin and Hobbs right you're
packing yep get your toothbrush Hobbs
we're out of here it's an outrage how
grown-ups have polluted the earth I
refuse to inherit a spoiled Planet I'm
leaving really where too you know
sometimes you're a real load to have
around I was just asking right as people
are saying there's no Planet B and so
what can we do well taking again some
insights from John's book we have a lot
of choices entrepreneurs will find
opportunities in this actually so our
choices what can we do our mitigation
right you know stop the problem don't
emit so much CO2 or CH4 just we can
adapt we can talk about that a little
bit or we can suffer this is this is a
quote of John Holdren's that John thinks
um you know he he cites and it's a very
perceptive one the climate problems big
urgent misunderstood which means
opportunity if you're an engineer with
the right mindset and this is the thing
entrepreneurs working forward trying
things business needs environmentalists
and environmentalists need business
which I think is a very hopeful Outlook
so this is this is really the Assumption
here um and so what if we Define where
do we need to get what if we say we
cannot exceed 2° C it's too Dreadful if
we go higher than that then we just
start working it backwards right like
any engineering project well okay how
many greenhouse gases can we emit what
are the pathways what do we have to do
try things don't wait for a grand
climate Summit of the whole world to
agree because that just doesn't seem to
be happening um this really is a time
when individual people corporations
Enterprises taking intelligent action
may have much more effect positive
effect than these Grand Vision meetings
which haven't seemed to yet right and
keep in mind that most of the
infrastructure we're going to have a few
decades from now is the stuff that gets
built now right it's going to be between
now and 2050 if we're looking at 2050
and that means changes should happen
quickly that means whatever new energy
source you have you know it will take
years to roll it out it always takes
years to adopt it so we really have a
Time urgency in all of this and so he
says immediate implementation is
essential you just can't wait and see
while doing R&D I like to make things
good enough so I know they're they're
going to be safe and they have a
reasonable chance of working yes but
after that you've got to do field
testing as part of your part of what
you're doing for real um and so there's
really there's really a lot we can do
and he says start small think big get
going and I think that's that's the
solution to the Calvin and Hobs dilemma
um
so let's get into the tricky thing of
geoengineering so this is you know what
we've just talked about could be talking
about new solar cells new Transportation
options all of that but what if we think
that this long lead time says we're
going to be in a heap of trouble before
we can get things adopted do we get into
geoengineering and boy there is a
complicated topic you guys have anything
you'd like to ask or say about what
we've just covered before we get into
this cuz this is a heavy
one okay yes there was one estimate that
only 5% of global GDP would go down
after 400,000 species died which seems
optimistic ludicrous yeah I mean
ludicrous optimistic SS yeah because if
if the web of life just
collapses we so much of what we do is
built on that I don't think 5% is really
going to cut 5% is the need that yeah
that's a very good point you know
there's 's a there's an old uh I think
it came from an old dunesbury thing back
years ago you have been scenario Rosal
we have been scario grossly right it's
just a little bit I agree with you when
you think about it from that
standpoint yeah I think there's going to
be a lot of suffering unless we wake up
in time to do something and I think
folks like you that's why I'm here on a
Friday afternoon I think folks like you
are the Hope really
um I mean I'll do what I can but you're
there are more of you when you're
younger you know I I think this really
is something that's going to be large in
your lives
and um geoengineering so your planet's
having problems here it's heating up
let's cool it and there are so many
ideas because people are creative and
you know it's funny because there are a
certain set of people who deny deny deny
there's any problem and then cling to
geoengineering and say ah we can keep
doing what we've been doing because we
can fix it this way it's really funny um
this has been pointed out to me and you
can see it people who switch suddenly
from there's no problem at all oh here's
the fix and so it's it's interesting
just watch this conversation um there's
I I you know I didn't want to have you
guys have to buy too many books but this
is an interesting one that can Caldera
uses in when he teaches this engineering
response to Global Climate Change and
I've got a few slides in here that come
from this it's it's a nice overview and
I'll I'll give you a really compact
overview but the thing to watch out for
in geoengineering as in anything large
you know the Wolves the the foxes and
such is possible unintended consequences
and if you've got those what's your undo
switch I'm always worried when there
doesn't seem to be an undo switch so
possible error reversibility if you do
find there's a dreadful side effect well
what are you going to do about it um
governance public acceptance all of
these are things that people worry about
so here are the sorts of strategies you
know how can you stabilize the climate
well diminish and use energy demand
perfect conservation makes so much sense
in so many ways we should be driving
that as hard as we can produce energy
without carbon emission absolutely solar
wind you know everything you can think
of along these green lines that are in
themselves economically
beneficial that just makes so much sense
remove some gases from the atmosphere
okay if you can and then reduce the
amount of solar radiation absorbed that
is where a lot of a lot of the action is
in people's attempts to stabilize the
climate or to think about it so now
we're in slides that are courtesy of Ken
Caldera it's very kind of him to let us
do this um here is something that I one
of my favorite charts the Earth's energy
balance and what I like about this is
that the um particular solution that
I've been working on I know I'm trying
to alter the reflection at the surface
and I'm trying not to mess up the water
cycle
uhoh can you write me a summary on the
rest of it later thank you um so those
those are some areas where you can start
trying to interact some are trying to
change the chemical composition so
change this part of it some are trying
to make more clouds or put in aerosols
so you can see this is just a beautiful
thing this is from uh this is from uh
Steve Schneider talk and it's from Keel
and Tren birth so it's a classic slide
um this is from this book the
engineering response to Global Climate
Change it's talking about carbon dioxide
removal strategies and those are
certainly ongoing um and solar radiation
management techniques um so carbon
dioxide removal is brilliant it's it's a
root cause of warming uh the problem is
we have a very dilute stream here over a
very large area and even if you're
trying to uh sequester your carbon your
carbon dioxide from a smoke stack it's
still rather challenging and I am
delighted that later in the quarter we
have Kate Mayer Who is an expert on
carbon sequestration coming to talk to
us uh November 14th I really want to
learn what she has to tell us solar
radiation management a lot of things
have been proposed um and so this is
from the Royal Society of geoengineering
report in 2009 here's some stuff
technology review blog in 2009 various
things people are trying um this is a
New York Times
article and there are various of these
that um strike me as okay and there are
some of these that really worry me um
ones that I tend to like are ones that
you could reverse so the seawater Mist I
don't have a problem with that floating
plastic Islands I'm convinced you're
making a swimming pool cover there but
it's a nice idea and you could possibly
take it back out um some of these are
just they strike me as nuts I mean
trillions of orbiting solar lenses wow
how much energy cost are we going to
have to get those up in space and how
would we take them back if we decided it
was a bad idea and we'd ruined our crops
you know it's um it's a fascinating mix
but people are imaginative and it's
great that people are thinking along
these lines one set that people really
like is the idea of adding stuff to our
atmosphere so stratospheric sulfate
aerosol injection is a very popular one
and it's what many people mean when they
talk about
geoengineering and what they say is you
know when mount pinba erupted things
cooled off you know it works and people
are studying I've been in meetings where
people are studying how much it will
cost to do it you know fixed Wing versus
I mean it just wow really but the thing
that worries me about this is what's the
undo switch if we decide this is bad for
some reason how do we undo it well you
just wait you know well it'll come out
what with precipitation sulfates and
rain I I think makes sulfuric acid which
doesn't help with ocean acidification so
I worry about this but the people who
want to study this I have the legitimate
claim that well at least if we
understand what the downsides will be
we'll understand it before somebody just
decides I'm going to do it because it's
dire and my island is drowning and I
just have to do it now at least if we
study thoroughly what the problems are
without running any tests that we
couldn't undo I I would add
you know it makes sense to understand
and so here are the models that they
have of well temperatures going up and
if we squirt this in at this point we
could lower temperature pretty rapidly
and let me get to the next one and then
I will and but here's here's one of
those big cautions this is one of those
that if you stopped your temperature so
let's say we decided this was a terrible
idea and we wanted to stop your
temperature starts popping up much more
rapidly than it would have in the first
place that is adding as as this finally
cleans itself out of the atmosphere you
actually pop your temperature up more
quickly than you would have in the first
place putting even more pressure on
species and on and on um sea level rise
and such so to me this seems like a a
dangerous thing to be experimenting with
at this point great to do paper studies
great to chase volcanoes and try to
understand it but other than that this
is one of those that worries me because
I don't see the undo switch and you had
a question yeah what's the difference
between the sulfur dioxide emissions
like of industry and why is it help like
why doesn't it lower if from industry
but it did with the volcano in fact
that's an irony that people have found
uh climate scientists whove really
looked at this is that when I was
growing up you know some years back we
had a lot more sulfur containing
pollution in the atmosphere and when we
cleaned that up I mean I grew up back
east and Boston was often in a haze of
of pollution and it's not anymore um and
when they cleaned it up so much actually
things got a little bit hotter so they
actually have found that the pollution
was in that strange way helping us but
you know there were so many other things
it wasn't helping so yeah it's an
excellent point um so so I'd say you
know proceed with things cautiously
understand G if I stopped suddenly again
this is Ken calderas he's warning us
about the hazards as well um but you
know um I would contend whatever we look
at let's be really careful about it I
love this picture you know what what are
we going to carefully try this is a
fragile ecosystem we have these guys you
guys you know we're all at stake here um
and so I contend that what we want is
something that we could control if we
needed to um so look at this as you know
call call it what you will CO2
temperature it's just a general control
diagram those of you who are doing
controls you know all about this let's
say that we did something there that
overcorrected drove us into the next ice
age well that's not good um we don't
want that either let's say that we
understand how to do and undo something
humans will always argue about something
but I'd be delighted if what they're
arguing about is what the set point
should be rather than you know rather
than something more disastrous so this I
think is is a good thing and I think
people people are starting to put labels
on these Steve Schneider put the label
of Eco engineering on on what I do um
soft geoengineering is another label
there have been whole workshops on that
um I think removable reversible features
are just absolutely essential we've got
to understand what we're doing well
enough to be able to remove or reverse
it or we or we really probably shouldn't
be doing it um and so now we power into
what my particular thing is so I got
very concerned about polar ice and I am
fully aware that I'm an engineer I mean
I have all Decades of engineering
experience that's where my degrees are
and therefore to get into this I've
really wanted to uh consult with climate
experts before really doing much here
and I will take you back to this
ice to this ice video that I had running
earlier if it will be kind enough to let
us run
oh come on yeah yeah wake up again so
this is compiled from a couple of ice
researchers I'm just going to let it run
while I describe it oh no it wants me to
describe it first you can see the month
and the year up here so this starts
actually a little before November 1979
but this is good enough and you're
looking down at the pole at the North
Pole from space Siberia Alaska I was
just in Barrow we would really like to
do some experiments there in Barrow last
week in fact to scope out what it will
cost do some experiments here's Canada
here's Greenland and what's really
interesting about this these two
researchers uh ignacius rigger and I
think it's John Wallace put this
together was they were trying to figure
out where their ice buoys were going
that's all these black and red tracks
where are they going things were
changing and what they picked up from
this was that reflectivity of ice has
changed and something really interesting
it's the ice albo feedback effect that
got me interested in this that is that
in the summer we've historically been
able to reflect a good deal of sunlight
coming in to the north reflecting off
multi-year very bright ice but when
you've got open ocean most of your
sunlight is absorbed so think about 95%
reflected here versus 95% absorbed and
then think further that when you've got
young ice some of you may have grown up
with ice and know about glare ice you
know you can hardly even see it's there
it can be very transparent and it can
absorb a lot of sunlight still even
though there's ice there and so what's
interesting about this just watch the
pulse by month it'll freeze back every
winter it'll disappear every summer to
some extent but just look at what's
happening to the bright ice as we go
along now we're in 1981
83 I call this thing the 34 seconds of
Doom um you can see people start putting
out far more buoys in a little while
because they're noticing something
really extraordinary is happening you
can see some of the ice goes out the
Fram straight here by Greenland but look
we're in 2000 do you do you remember how
much ice ice we had before bright ice
we're freezing every winter fine but we
don't have this bright ice
anymore and so over the last few years
what climate scientists have gone from
in 2006 saying this was a responsible
for about 20% of global temperature rise
this taking in more energy in the summer
more solar energy in the summer now that
now falling out of their models is it's
about a third of global temperature rise
comes from this so I was looking for
something high impact that I could work
on and I seem to have found it
um and so that's that's what I'm working
on is how on Earth can you slow the Melt
or maybe even restore multi-year polar
ice and so the ipcc when they predicted
you know back to the ipcc fourth
assessment they had a broad range of
predictions of what was going to happen
to ice extent back in 2007 and this was
their average was this red line and the
blue is all the range you know you get a
lot of scientists together there'll be a
diversity of opinion and the black line
is what actually happened this was 2007
and then I added in I added in the 2012
point and so this is this is really
alarming they they caught that this is a
positive feedback loop but they didn't
catch how fast it was going to go and so
this is just the area extent we're down
50% from what we were in the 1979 to
1990 mean but in volume we're down to a
quarter of what we had we've lost 3/4 of
the thickness that we had of the volume
so it's not such a good situation and
then from that video with the buoys
blanked out so it's easy to see June
1980 June 2002 June 2012 so this is one
of the big levers on climate change and
it's got a lot to do with just a few
cities are highlighted of how much per
year cities are paying to adapt somebody
in here talked about wanting to
understand adaptation
um this is what cities are doing they're
spending New York City is spending right
now $2 billion a year to do things that
are very that's a graphic artist's
Vision we well right this is what people
fear um they're spending $2 billion do a
year to do very simple things like let's
make our subway system work let you know
even if we have a big storm let's have
our septic outfalls come out above what
our sea level is you know simple
engineering things is very costly and
you look um I've been advised not to
show every point you have many people
are doing big studies on this but if you
show just a few you can see the enormous
economic impact this has already back to
your point about GDP right a lot of
money is going to Shoring things up and
the cost right now is billions a year
but trillions are predicted after 2050
if sea levels keep Rising as predicted
and you know this could actually be be
the sort of things that we worrying
about in the future um we also have
we've lost a rather stabilizing force in
that historically the arctic's been very
very cold compared to the rest of the
world and the jet streams have been very
stable patterns and one statement I
heard at the last agu I was at American
geophysical union meeting was that over
the course of human history of
civilization the 20,000 years of
civilization we've had very stable
weather patterns these jet streams have
stayed very stable and they aren't
anymore they're wavier it's like a small
perturbation and persuade it to can can
just be the driving force for a big
shift and so we're ending up with what
people regard as weird weather a weird
weather pattern like we have this big
drought pattern that may suddenly shift
into a different pattern because things
aren't that stable anymore makes it
pretty difficult to plan where you're
going to have your population centers
and your Coastal buildings and your
crops and so you know life has gotten a
bit more challenging and this also
drives more severe
storms and horrible human costs and so
we have options right we can do
nothing that's that's sort of the
default option and there are a lot of
dreadful problems that people say result
we can look at these other options
mitigation that's going to the source
right it's a long-term solution this is
what we absolutely should do this is
what most of you are focused on here in
the class what can I do to do a
different Energy Solution a different
Transportation solution Heavens yes um
but it's going to take a while to adopt
it and that's what worries me and keeps
me motivated on what I'm doing here's
the adaptation the you know the human
adaptation billions of dollars a year
Shore up you know build levies all all
this stuff geoengineering here's another
summation of these some look interesting
some look risky maybe irreversible um
really be careful before we're
implementing these or before we're doing
much in the way of testing would be my
advice uh um and so you know my solution
is to try to be as gentle as possible to
reboot ice where it's melting do a very
localized not not put something in the
atmosphere where you're hoping you
understand your wind patterns hoping it
goes the right place do something local
do something you could undo if our stuff
got frozen into the ice and we couldn't
remove it okay is it harmless and do we
have a way to melt ice oh yeah soot we
are so good at
so I think that you know I think this is
a rather safe thing to try but believe
me I'm Consulting with all the experts I
can find to do this critical thing first
Do no
harm um so we've been testing for years
um we've had I've been at this for about
eight years and we've done field testing
for about six of them we've had a nice
test Pond laboratory in uh in another
state we've had one in uh California
we've had one in Canada uh I've got a
wonderful collaborator Sati chedy who's
been building these instrumentation
platforms for us he started something
called a polar technology conference 10
years ago that is in the nassa parking
lot near here that has grown so their
last one was in Annapolis with lots and
lots of people there he is Satish this
is Tony whose Lake I was just showing
his friend Doug me with my forgive me
Cal cap and six six years of of lab and
field tests have been really critical to
developing some interesting
materials and our critical questions are
what are the best materials and how much
do they slow the Melt and can we apply
them maybe to help with a current
problem like the drought and I do have
time to pass them around so we have a a
little bit of a diversity of materials
here I couldn't find plastic cups when I
came in so I'm going to float one
thing but I'm thirsty and I'm not going
to drink this afterwards although we
have tested some of this on on drinking
water I've never actually swallowed
this pour a few
out and you can just see this guy
floating around this is actually um
Hollow glass spheres of of various ways
thinking that sand floating sand is
about as harmless as you can get we've
been doing a lot of work on things like
this I don't care if Firefox had a
problem and crashed um
and then another one and again plastic
cups are awfully handy but we'll just
take what we got okay anybody worries
about getting wet you might not want to
do this maybe I should just show it um
what we
found is that a material that you can
find in your
kitchen works really well to make very
bright
ice and I don't know if you'll be able
to see it but yeah this is so much much
better with cups but this is much
Brighter Than This starts out than
standard ice and it is safe enough to
drink which is the next part that
usually works better with a cup
but and it's it's much brighter so it's
safe stuff and what we're trying to
understand is how wet we can get our
equipment here um what we're trying to
understand is what works best where that
particular material that makes bright
ice from something that you can find in
your kitchen actually hasn't worked so
well in this testing out here in in the
lower 48 as opposed to Glass stuff
that's going around which is one of my
favorite materials we've obviously tried
many materials but um we think it might
in the Arctic and that's part of the
motivation of well if this is meant for
the Arctic let's try it in the Arctic
and so I was up there last week in
perrow looking at what their
temperatures are like what water and air
temperatures are like what are the
logistics what's it going to cost us to
do a test there and so fundraising is a
big part of what we do to to try to get
okay this is how much we're going to
need this is this is how we're going to
prove it so we've gotten to this point
we think we can help with the drought
it's it's an interesting project and it
gives me this whole lens through what
we've done with oh your your class the
global entrepreneurship and marketing
class the clean tech open sustainable
Silicon Valley there are a lot of
accelerators now if you have a bright
idea um that you can try to get some
help with so that's sort of my story on
trying to slow down the Melt of the
Polar Ice um my own environmental
nonprofit and then I wanted to just have
a closing discussion here to encourage
you to do a little bit of reading for
next week I'll put some of those
readings about Green Building and about
smart grid from previous years's
lectures again don't feel obligated to
read all the readings but there are some
total gems up there on the coursework
site if you have time so um in our
closing discussion we actually have a
little more than seven minutes left this
is great I talked fast first any
questions and then I would ask you guys
to to continue your discussions among
yourselves of what's your big dream but
questions first yeah can you elaborate a
little bit more on how technology
developing would help out
ah yeah if you're good at cooling things
and reflecting sunlight then you can
probably help reduce evaporation from
reservoirs and that is a really
interesting Fallout that we noticed
early on I had what is probably a very
backwards view of things it's like my
gosh my problem is the polar ice melt I
mean you look at this this is pretty
dire and we're all right here suffering
from this right but if you look at that
this affecting the entire planet at once
you say well there's this is awfully
urgent too and of course the change in
weather pattern may be the cause in the
drought I don't want to be distracted
from this but this is hard to get funded
whereas being able to preserve you know
10 or 20% of your water supply that
otherwise would have been lost is easy
to easier to fund and so I think it it's
actually see backwards to my original
thinking but I I have grown um I think
actually we may need to make that play
first um so that which will give us a
lovely test bed to develop some of the
materials we need for up here in these
tougher locals by the way I for
completely forgot to mention I guess
NASA has gotten very interested in what
we're doing we have a number of groups
that are really interested that may be
able to be enormously helpful that also
add credibility to what we're doing
which it which will help us get it out
there too but yeah that's um some of the
same materials that we're using is the
idea and uh yeah it could really be
helpful and now that people isn't it
funny I mean it's year three when people
finally get it you finally get the
announcements and there's finally going
to be some economic disincentive for you
know Watering your lawn too much it's
like really year three I mean I I think
the same thing has happened with the
polar ice melt you people are getting it
now um anyway that's yeah that's that's
what we're talking about um yes uh who
would be in charged of deying these
Technologies on cap and maintaining yes
so so I was up there exploring who could
help because
um um the logistics up there are very
different than around here and there's
actually um Native corporations
organizations up there there's there's a
lot of native people who live up there
and they have a really interesting
Arrangement and they have an enormous
understanding of course of what you have
to do up there and I went up there I
have to say just completely ignorant
it's just but I just have to learn about
this place so I can see whether we can
work up there because it's really
important to do some on-site testing and
I kind of expected to get into town and
just have oh gosh another scientists
they just don't understand ah instead I
really got embraced by this no I guess
not anybody else is up there trying to
save the ice and trying to reverse the
Melt and so the people I was talking to
were remarkable very very welcoming and
and talking one in particular was
telling about how he and his dad and his
brother had floated off on some ice
unintendedly while they were out whale
hunting which is a big part of the
culture and the economy up there the
tradition and they were out there
hunting it was a few years ago cuz this
has been going on for a bit and all of a
sudden the ice all around them melted
what what connected them melted and
they're suddenly off there and it's like
falling off a spaceship in space without
a
tether and they were pretty sure they
were not going to get rescued you know
they and the dad is trying to do the
math of should I throw your kids across
they you know or or should I go across
and get out no we've got to stick
together you know just by their wits
trying to figure out what the right
thing is with the fog raising all around
them and they know they're invis visible
took him a long time for a helicopter to
find him they set the sled and all their
clothes on fire trying to attract you
know just fortunately their dad with his
last couple seconds of cell phone left a
message at 911 so somebody knew roughly
where they were heading but people like
that are just amazed this this
particular person he was amazing to talk
to um was really amazed that the rest of
the world cares about this I mean he
knows that the buildings are falling
apart because of permafrost melt and he
knows that hunting for whales is much
more hazardous and people you know put
in months building these month and a
half building these straight tracks that
they'll be able to escape if they need
to and drag the whale back and you know
just all these things they do and then
the ice breaks up and they've lost that
month and a half of work of the whole
you know the whole collection of people
the whole village and and it's like you
care about this and I've just yeah this
has an impact on the rest of the world
you know that's that's our angle but
they're they're just seeing the problem
in their face so that you know I hadn't
understood their day-to-day problems and
they hadn't really gotten out of the
day-to-day gee our way of life is
disappearing to wow this is affecting
the whole world of course everybody
cares and so I think there's a real
possibility to work together that I
found really exciting and they help you
I mean they for a cost of course that's
part of what I had to figure out was
what will it cost they're be guards out
there if you're working on the ice to
help uh you know shoe them away in case
they decide to investigate the wrong way
it's just a lot of you know how on Earth
do you work up there so it's um yeah
there so there's people in place who
help and there's a lot of scientific
installations um and yeah I I could go
on and on about my travel Memoirs
obviously this had made a great
impression on me uh but that's probably
offline for for more but yeah work
through people who live there anyone
else any other
questions yes so is the idea to try to
cover the ice with the material you put
the water bottle or that's one way to do
it um another way is actually I've made
sure what I work on is floatable so if
you want the highest albo shift right
away there there's some much brighter
materials that I could bring this is
just one that's in a good size to pass
around but um you have the highest albo
shift here if you're going from where
was it my
friends ah I guess I must have put it
way back there in the ice but you you
saw it right yeah the highest albo shift
from going to from open ocean or very
young ice to going to something very
bright and so you could float it even
but you know there's a lot of concern
which is justifiable of how will you
contain this how will you know where it
goes how will you make sure somebody
isn't eating it how will you make sure
if they do eat it it isn't harmful
there's a lot of things you have to look
at to make sure
that you understand don't cause
unintended harm and that there's an undo
switch and so those those are the
constraints and they're pretty serious
constraints so personally I love the one
that I dare you know I could eat my ice
cube I I like that a lot but it performs
beautifully in the lab NASA has has
confirmed this on small scale but it
performed miserably in field testing on
this this uh Lake uh in Minnesota last
winter and it's like hm very different
weather patterns but we really need to
do that's a Next Step a vital Next Step
do a test up there and see how does it
work up there in the Arctic and and we
know why it performed miserably in in
Minnesota but will those same conditions
apply up there because that's the that's
the safest
one
so how much coverage do you want how
dense do you want coverage to be yeah
very important you don't want to I used
to show a slide about what the EOS
system under the ice is because you
don't want what you really want to do is
try to bring back ice likee conditions
and having all the ice gone has been an
enormous Eco impact for all all the life
underneath so you want to build it back
like that but you don't want to have you
know some crazy plastic sheet out there
or something you know or something
that's going to block all your sunlight
or all your traffic of being able to get
through so how do you reboot it with the
least material you can the thin
material probably fairly sparse probably
you know allowing a lot of traffic
through um seems the right way to go and
also to my mind reservoirs you know if
you're going to do this you're probably
going to want to have some parts covered
at some time but make sure they're
uncovered at others so the plant life
under there is going to still be
thriving too so there's a lot of
constraints to respect the natural
system it's part of why people who
support us sometimes wonder why does
this take so long like well we're a
we're running on a shoe string literally
a Sho string and and B it's just there's
a lot to consider and try to try to make
sure that we are adhering to that first
Do no
harm so any any other questions I think
we've actually ended our time guys
you're a fantastic group I really look
forward to our time together this term
and please don't hesitate email me if
you if you need to did I stick my
contact info here at the end I probably
should
have yeah um there that's how to reach
me don't hesitate I'm happy to do office
hours and such if you need or just to
chat or just to email okay thanks a lot
and uh do sign in and you know all of
that